[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is Byron
Bowers who is one of the most
interesting people I've ever talked to
he's also incredibly funny and has a new
stand-up special on Hulu called
spiritual n-word check that out it's
incredible it really is one of a kind
you've also seen him on the Eric Andre
show he was on the Pete home show he was
also he's always showing up in some of
my favorite movies like he was
incredible in the movie honeyboy uh the
Shia LaBeouf movie he's really really
something and I'm so glad we got to sit
down here's a little taste once you
start reading like self-help books and
Tony Robbins and stuff and you listen to
Jay-Z album you're like oh it's a lot of
same stuff he dropping a lot of like
innuendos right I'm not a businessman no
business man yeah so it's crazy it seems
like something Tony Robbins would say
yeah don't be a businessman be a
business man write that down
so excited for you guys to hear the rest
of this conversation if you like this uh
it's the kind of thing with me maybe if
you like this kind of thing maybe you
want to see me do stand-up comedy I'm
currently on tour you can go to
petehomes.com for tickets uh the next
city is coming up are Grand Rapids San
Diego in New Orleans but you'll see on
the website I'm coming I'm coming
everywhere I'm going everywhere so
sounds better I'm going everywhere go to
petehomes.com or if you're going to be
in the Los Angeles area I do a monthly
show there at Largo a beautiful theater
always the highlight of my month go to
largo-la.com for tickets always have
some of the best comedians in the world
on that show as well as music we've had
Phoebe Bridgers we've had Bo Burnham
we've had Sarah Silverman Judd Apatow
Zach Galifianakis incredible always fun
go to largo-la.com I hope you can be
there on March 29th and if you're in
another city go to petehomes.com and
please see if I'm coming to a town
coming to a town near you only one ad up
top which is our friends at Living
Libations this is one of the easiest and
best ways to support this show because
living Libations makes natural premium
but also easy to understand ingredients
beauty products skin products teeth
products baby products they have
something natural and wonderful to
replace all sorts of random chemical
nightmares you might have hiding in your
medicine cabinet whether it's a
moisturizer you put on something for
your gums something for your baby's butt
living Libations has the list of
ingredients that you will recognize and
be able to pronounce that are real and
natural but living Libations also make
somebody the best products in the world
full stop the example I always use is
their Ginger exfoliating scrub not only
do I recognize every single ingredient
on the small list of ingredients as
opposed to some random thing you get at
CVS that has all these chemicals linked
to disease and just toxicity levels that
aren't intended for humans the gender
exfoliating scrub is also just the most
badass and effective exfoliant I've ever
used in my life so these aren't sort of
like also rayon or like weak natural
alternatives these are strong high
quality effective powerful and
nature-based replacements for for things
made by corporations that just don't
care about you whatsoever living
Libations is the solution to chemicals
and it's also the solution to a lot of
your your health and beauty needs like
best skin ever the moisturizer both Val
and I use one bottle lasts an incredibly
long time by the way I'm just realizing
as I'm recording this I haven't had to
re-up in a very long time not only will
you recognize all the ingredients but it
keeps your skin looking great smells
great keeps you looking great whatever
your skin needs whatever your body your
eyes your your kids we get the love the
sun zinc based sunblock for Leela it's
wonderful because she has to wear
sunblock every day in the summer and you
know frankly in the spring too here in
California it's wonderful knowing I'm
putting something on her that isn't
overloaded with chemicals that is made
from natural things that actually works
but I can feel good about putting it on
my daughter I can feel good about
putting it on my body because what you
put on your body gets in your body gets
in your blood it's like eating it it's
basically absorbed into you so we should
be careful about what we eat and we
should be deliberate and mindful about
what we put on our skin as well and
living Libations is here to save the day
so to give it a try and show your
support of the show go to
livinglibations.com weird and you'll get
15 off everything and anything you see
on that website show support for your
body show support for the show
livinglibations.com weird for 15 off all
right everybody enjoy this chat with
Byron Bowers get into it right here
right here here this is you this is this
is your close right here here's your
wide I might just stay at this the
skylights
you got blinds for it that's that's uh
yeah you're the first and only how many
hundreds of episodes have we done no
one's ever been like Skylight One Two
there is a blind on that Skylight yeah
and it's closed that's the yeah I guess
people don't pay attention to
yeah well I mean I went to school for
engineering so that's your architecture
always jumps out I always look at how
things are made
well you just lost the truck you know
right yeah well I noticed your truck
hence the specific maker of the truck
yeah and the truck itself it's a Porsche
though isn't it yeah Porsche makes
tracks they make uh Sports wagons they
call them okay sports wagon and um
they're very good at engineering and
design and we're fine and refining is
push German
yeah Porsche did you know that I did
because I didn't know if I caught you
like being like no no yeah but I'm just
going through all the research of uh
you know of the of the person the
engineer who started a Porsche that's
his last name yeah it's a dude yeah
what's his first name uh
yeah Ferdinand Porsche yep because if
you're [__] with me no you could
Google it Ferdinand and uh
I don't know why it's funny yeah and he
made the Volkswagen he created the
Volkswagen
this is the dark history that's the dark
history of it that's towards this dark
you know we all got dark past right you
know I didn't know Porsche was the same
dude that made I thought that was
someone named Volkswagen no Volkswagen
means people's car yeah and it was
Hitler's idea yeah
at the time you know he had like
brainstorming sessions yeah they would
talk and he was like hello you know I
want a people I want to call for the
people I'm a man I'm gonna be a man of
people I got Big Dreams yeah and and uh
Ferdinand I was like I got it you know
and a little bubbly thing just died in
the Volkswagen yeah the design the
people's car somebody told me something
here's an interesting Hitler I know
Hitler fact
was that when they would do his address
his radio address
I guess he gave a lot of people radios
everybody got a radio because you know
as a dictator you have to oh yeah speak
to the people you have to get them your
message yeah so it seems like cool like
oh free radio and it's a text write-off
are you governing an island I don't know
the budget like yeah of course oh yeah
no they weren't paying for those radios
they were like there's a way to get this
free yeah you see these guys with the
guns yeah I make the radios there you go
everybody okay
I'm for the people remember that radio
for the people folks radio
and then what they would do somebody
just told me this at the beginning if
you turn your radio on to the station
that was going to have his address on it
yeah it would play there's like Unholy
frequencies there's there's certain
chords back in the day back in like
Mozart's day it was illegal to play
certain chords because they were
considered demonic and you know these
chords they just make you feel weird
some of them are baked Into The Simpsons
himself
it's supposedly like one of the it's
like record yeah now we're smoking weed
and watching YouTube right now but I
mean that's the history of hip-hop too
tell me what these certain low bass
frequencies create anger and well they
sound like growling that's why when you
put it on you you bounce and stuff like
that right you know you get your
adrenaline to go to the club and you you
get adrenaline going well you you can't
tell my caveman brain when it hears a
subwoofer that it's not a bear
you know what I mean
like it's shaking you and it's growling
it's the same with your loud ass car
sorry I just made fun of your car yeah
but your car sounds like a tiger well I
like yeah I like that that's what I mean
yeah so you're harnessing you're not
like a bass too so you got a bear inside
and a tiger so you got a whole zoo
or a whole jungle I guess chasing people
but that's what it is we're always
trying to borrow attributes from the
Animal Kingdom yeah and when you're a
sport if you wear a jersey a Chicago
Bears Jersey you're doing it twice
the Bears this football team is saying
we're like Bears you're saying I'm like
a football player who's like a bear it's
like twice removed but really at the end
of the day you could just wear a t-shirt
that says don't [__] with me I'm like a
bear or I'm strong like a bear or I have
food and you don't because I'm a bear
that's also hip hop I'm a bear but I'm a
losing bear well bears do lose a lot but
I'll stay in the cold and then the
baseball team was a cook so yeah they
representing the cook when they grow up
they'll play football oh is that where
they get the football player and then we
like to hook like we outside we ah but
inside we like to cuddle
in the locker room there's a lot of
just a sticky paw for like yeah honey I
never seen y'all have seen the bear eat
honey but the funny thing I've seen
about anything that's a weird thing when
it wakes up and it dances on the tree
get the fur off yeah yeah oh that's
hilarious if you put a hip hop beat over
there I mean well that's the other thing
so the other thing saying I'm like a
bear is very it makes a lot of sense
evolutionarily yeah but hip-hop is also
a lot about [__] and procreating and
also having a crew and it's like there's
more of us than you it's very it's not
what I'm saying is like Humanity doesn't
really change we're still expressing
like my genes reproduce your genes don't
reproduce women want to have sex with me
and make more of me women don't want to
have sex with you and I'm a bang yo girl
exactly I was just thinking about that
song and I probably [__] your [__]
the first line
a joke about it yeah Parks uh uh get
money right the biggie this but you you
don't realize now that I'm at the A and
I still listen to 2000 era hip hop yeah
which is I like because every era is
different right uh my air is like all
the hustlers like now we getting money
so it's a lot of business advice in
there you know it's just the Art of War
yeah a lot of it was the article yeah at
the time because those guys are
billionaires now uh yeah Diddy yeah and
if you once you start reading like
self-help books and Tony Robbins and
stuff and you listen to Jay-Z album you
like oh it's a lot of them same stuff he
dropping a lot of like innuendos right
I'm not a businessman I'm a business man
yeah so it's crazy it seems like
something Tony Robbins would say yeah
don't be a businessman be a business man
write that down
banana hands and that would be his rap
name banana hands bananas banana hands
chops
um but yeah man but then you you like
now I just hit the fours and I'm like
listening his music I was like man we
was getting advice from like 20 years 20
years yeah and they were older to us at
the time you know I think about this all
the time the people that I admired
looking back like even sports players
too you're athletes you'd be like that
dude was 26 years old why was I or
actors oh my God what's he doing and now
that I'm I'm also in my 40s I'm like why
was I ever interested in what Leonardo
DiCaprio had to say you know what I mean
or whoever yeah as you look at them now
yeah that's the thing you looking at
these people now it's like whoa but also
me now there's a humbling there too like
I think because I'm 43 I have more
wisdom and that's probably true than
when I was 23 but I'm I'm still full of
[__] compared to me at what
63 53 but then it starts to go away and
then I have less wisdom when I'm 73.
come on I'm like where's pre where's
Peak I don't know if it's a peak because
when you add dating into the situation
and um
you know and then you like oh and like
my girl be like you so immature and
um
an adult enough to be like
you got damn right
that's just who I'm gonna be you mean
it's a choice to stay silly you just
know you just embrace it yeah because my
granddaddy would like walk in front of
the TV naked like what y'all watching
like that was the jokes
you know me on the way to the bathroom
the bathroom's right next to the TV and
that's the jokes you know but he did it
as a bet you man yeah it's a joke yeah
you know so that's my my humor's gonna
be like that was it funny when you were
a kid oh it definitely was funny yeah it
definitely farts farts was funny when
you were a kid unless a woman did it
right to camera he does it right to
camera unless a woman did it
sometimes lady fart it's a special fart
well it's a special it is it's a special
sound we talk about back to the to the
vibration yes it is the Simpson uh thing
yeah you know
but I think it's different depends on
like you know
if you like
lick booty or not then yeah
affects you different
the longer you've been together and the
you know if you do certain things then
it's like
yeah yeah yeah but they're still
[__] that I I'm gonna call [__]
on this premise because if you want to
toss salad but you're not thinking about
that you're not in the room watching
them that's a whole different now I'm
not as long as there's a door people do
is people are probably in the room while
they ladies doing that watching it like
you know like you know putting a napkin
under their neck you know I mean he like
the head of five-star restaurant
like an Olive Garden
yeah I remember because I thought that
was fancy too when I was young I didn't
know I didn't know that it was one of
the few restaurants that advertised you
know what I mean like Regular Ad
restaurants don't have ads yeah and it's
one of the only at the place I live like
it was the fancy where's that where's
that well I grew up in a Clarkston like
part of Atlanta Georgia so that and Red
Lobster was the like yeah the Chili's
yeah the Chili's dropped yeah and then
you like you know you get older you like
another thing you like man what was we
didn't know it was Leonardo DiCaprio yep
yeah you didn't realize that Chili's was
Leonardo DiCaprio and a lot of people
freeze on chilies that's okay there's a
lot of people yeah but I mean that's the
part I mean that's the blessing I think
of going through life and getting wisdom
because America is a version that the
more I leave the country you okay we're
the
we're the the Adolescent the Adolescent
of Earth of the all the countries yeah
and I take when I go to certain places
I'm not I'm here as a black man when I
go to certain places I'm in America and
we've done is the first day ever the
first one that's how identity how I
didn't identify you but we've done
things in other countries right that if
we knew we wouldn't be proud of but as
an American I still take ownership of
that and still be like we number one you
know what I mean but you think there are
things like we should be embarrassed by
like bad practices
um
like there's a bit of Shame
associated with it yeah we're not the
we're not the best it's just stuff we
don't know about right yeah we have good
PR yeah we got a good PR to ourselves
good propaganda you know I mean it was
the the propagators of the propaganda
are the people yeah so but we all get a
radio yeah we do get it we get our
version of the radio but it's a blessing
it's a blessing in that but it's still
like oh it's like when you see the video
games from other countries and we're the
bad guys but here we play video games
and we shoot at other right people that
speak other languages we don't even know
where they're from right but then you
see them wearing American flags and the
kids are like get them I didn't know
that was a thing they were video games
video games it's the opposite and it's
like
but aren't those aware of those games
being made because Call of Duty and all
that stuff that's also part of
propaganda by the way when I say
propaganda that's what I'm saying they
gotta sell as a business person they got
to sell
to the Russians too who the Russians
gonna shoot
races ain't gonna shoot Russians who are
you shooting they got to shoot us
they're looking they're looking at the
map and being like let's change it yeah
let's swap it up we're gonna put is that
true is that is it I've seen footage of
of a game where we we the bad guys like
we invaded them and I'm like
I'm like oh [__] you know right but it
is what it is I've never thought about
that ain't this crazy
yeah my friend because my first time to
the Middle East that's when I first time
experiencing being an American well tell
me about that and uh where were you I
went to Bahrain in 2006 uh to do
stand-up and
um you know being in that that's not a
place I guess a lot of it's more
Africans golden Americans when you pull
your passport out in this blue it's like
an extra stair like really like like and
it could be it's For Better or For Worse
but luckily because of rap music is for
the better
the hip-hop family yeah okay yeah
because that that take that has taken us
worldwide but some Africans and other
countries have bad reputations okay so
it's almost a relief but then it's like
wait are you one of the uh
when they think you're African if they
might think you're African there's a set
of stereotypes oh that's a set of
stereotypes yeah whatever I guess I
don't want to propagate them but they're
bad they're it's not all good in their
places like like it's the same like you
know if you hear a Nigerian scam here
yeah and but like Nigerian prince yeah
or Nigerian people
is that run by Nigerians that would be
funny if they're if you're a Nigerian
doing a scam and they're like let's give
Nigeria a shout out yeah like let's make
a prince from our country nothing else
will be traceable back to us but a
little shout out to Nigeria is everybody
princess in Nigeria and everybody lose
like a scam not made by Nigerians to me
but I got Nigerian friends and they like
they do it the scam they they might uh
you know somebody wrote my homeboy one
time
and then he he was like this ain't gonna
work I'm not Jerry and then he was like
oh well look we looking for credit card
information and all type of stuff you
know what I mean so okay so that is a
okay that's not a thing but it's a it's
a scary thing but I'm an outsider so
okay are you Nigerian no well DNA wise
DNA I know I know you're you were born
here yeah but I'm I didn't know I
thought I would be like got her I was
gunning and stuff like that and we got
an idea 23 you did it it was like
Nigerian and I was like I called all my
Nigerian friends and I was like
yeah yeah you know because the first
time I remember going to a Nigerian
house
it was like walking into a
racist person house almost
the way this family was being they were
one of the uncles who's from Nigeria
because
I'm an American oh he was racist to you
yeah he was like who you know who's like
jokingly who let this white man wolf in
the house really because that's the day
I found out that's when I stopped
calling myself African-American too and
I was like oh it's a separate thing
because they're African-Americans right
I'm black you know what I mean right but
it was explaining my homeboy was like oh
you Nigerian who don't know he Nigerian
but then I later found out we're we're
all a lot of us are mixed blood that's
what I heard we're not pure African so
and we're a little bit more
uh trained to the American lifestyle
hence the white man wolf comment okay
yeah so and then I did my DNA test and I
found out that I'm Nigerian and Sierra
Leone and like Congolese and like all
these
things but then I'm like oh I'm mixed
with people that people don't like who
got with the bad reputation should I say
um Nigerian who got bad reputations
um uh 15 European German who got bad
reputation French you know how they are
uh
uh uh Irish
okay
um and then I'm gonna smidget Iranian
too and I'm like damn there's a lot of
[__] going on in my in my DNA and
before the internet that's all there was
yeah but the discovery of it is like I'm
like well we Pat when we like passed
around it's just a thing I'm still
trying to figure out like how did these
all these mixtures happen right but I
know my name is like Irish and Celtic
wheels and stuff like that you okay so
all right so there's lots of different
it's interesting how different groups
are racist to other groups so you're
saying everybody's to me Africans are
racist towards Well everybody's a lack
of sales because East and West not as a
whole but this house you went into tell
me what the East and West are have
issues some underlying issues East
African West Africa yeah have some
underlying issues right this is I was
actually just thinking about this not as
a movie but I was like white people
right that are xenophobic and racist and
aggressively nationalistic right like
the race War people let's say let's jump
150 years after a horrible thing into
the future now it's just white people in
this weird like I'm saying like just
play it out what do you want to happen
spiritually go to the past go to win or
go to the past when when the Irish
landed or when the Italians landed
that's my point like you just find
another way race to me is just the
laziest because it's overt it's it's a
skin color and it's a culture and it's a
food and it's a different clothes
clothing and all these things that are
so obvious so what we really don't like
is separateness and and unknown I I'm
not I'm saying obviously can go deeper
than that yeah but if it all is just all
white people and and your plan worked
and now it it does look like 1941 or
whatever even though obviously there
were diverse different groups there too
but let's say it's all white people
you'd still find another way it happens
it's Irish that's my Protestant it's
Catholic it's left-handed that's my
that's what I that's my observation it's
like even because I I had the joke about
it's people you don't like in your own
family and they look like you that's
well that's it they just might wear
glasses they make they macaroni and
cheese a little different you know give
me when they use ghee instead of butter
right right [__] them well that's what
I'm saying is there's some you can say
whatever you want there's something
going on that we have something about
ourselves that we hate yeah and it's so
uncomfortable to hold on to it that I
project it on to anyone yeah and even if
they're other people that look like me
for me of course they look like me it's
almost easier because you know they're
dumb [__] just like me I'm like look at
this dumb [__] filled with rage filled
with hate filled with shame filled with
guilt and then I'd start what I'm saying
is but that's what makes being an adult
[__] because you know now that everybody
got the [__] in them so the older you
get you really just don't care about
nothing when you get back in that phase
again because you know like the world is
full of [__] you you're saying getting
to a certain age and admitting and yeah
pretending yeah and coming to grips with
that coming to grips you got it's coming
to grips with like your your part of you
that's full of [__] yes like when my
girl said I'm in mature and I'm like
okay
uh thanks for the discovery I'm gonna
play with this yeah I mean yes and to
come in the grips with that
and the brain is something peaceful
about it of course but then you have you
accept that in other people there's
something peaceful about that
precisely yep when you remove the burden
of knowing everything for yourself you
can relax and other people don't need to
know everything either and then we're
all just kind of swimming around the
same soup you got to get involved with
no political or conversations no more
nothing because it's like I don't know
[__] right right
and then you just go sound did you your
special I was watching a special that
opened with that mushroom thing do you
do psychedelics is that a thing it it is
a thing I don't do it I've had some some
experiences on it
all of them been great even the worst
ones are profound tell me
um because this is kind of a mushroomy
thing when I've taken mushrooms I've
been like oh my God everybody's just in
here you know what I mean they're just
in here having their own thing I don't
know what's going on in you I we do our
best communicating our faces our
preferences our likes our dislikes but
really like there's this really strange
inner Galaxy that's always different
it's crazy that we're all just sitting
on the subway
there's 150 galaxies you know what I'm
saying and I'm like and no one knows
what's going on like the I don't know
what's going on inside of you and you
don't know what's going on inside of me
and when you take mushrooms you really
realize like oh my God we're all out
we're all having our own trip I agree
but you know because I see patterns
right so the smallest thing becomes the
biggest thing and vice versa it just
fluctuates in that pattern now waveform
which goes on forever
you know if you break or you cut a
circle in half you remember the sign
cosine I don't know if you good in
Geometry but it's a wave that goes on
forever and that's life ups and downs
right yeah okay sunrise sunset you know
et cetera et cetera Breathe In Breathe
Out breathe in breathe out I came with
this off based off a woman's cycle
oh okay a long time ago because it's a
period of cleansing it's a period of
release of eggs it's a time of feeling
that men don't have and I was like man
we don't get a chance we go so hard we
don't get a chance to go through this
and then I thought about the moon and
all that so I came up with this whole
chart now I'm saying it's because well
you came up with a chart yeah everything
yeah sure but was it to mimic or to
impose some sort of cycle onto a man no
it was that's a good idea it was the
cycle of of life that we don't pay
attention to it's the pattern it's
before I did shrooms by the way so I
already had this before and I was like
your life your life is like this yeah
right your life is you born and you die
but in that it's all these things yeah
you know this many sunrises this many
moons this many heartbreaks and it's
just all these lines and to me it was a
way to gauge this is the engineering
part that oh if I'm up here then then
this is gonna probably be the natural
thing so how do I keep this from going
not dropping all the way here but dip
and go up even more in-depth and do that
right before it goes before health and
stuff that's interesting it's like
looking at a sound wave and you're like
can we make it a smaller curve yeah now
this the highs might be less High though
if you do that well
it depends on if all the highs will be
high it's like the stock market your
highs will get higher you
like Apple's still a hundred dollar
stock I mean there used to be three
dollars when it used to be three dollars
yeah so that even even with it even if
it crashes it's gonna crash to 90 it's
not gonna crash all the way down to
three right so the highs are higher and
the lows are higher too
if the pattern is going up if that's the
thing you can get it to go up okay so
it's not just making have health
insurance if you break your leg you get
taken care of or what I call covet I
only had it for like three days I only
tested negative for three days versus
people I know who you know three weeks
and six months of not breathing and
stuff like that wow wow so
um now this goes back to what you were
saying how everybody's on the on there
in this existing having their own trip
all these ups and downs in your body and
you don't know where they're at
digesting food or yeah they have
breakfast some people didn't have
breakfast they losing energy some people
call for the gaining energy yeah so I
experience with you
experience
and it's coming at so many different
waves and I mean I'm my last trip I was
like oh the Earth is dying oh I'm dying
I'm in sync with the with the Earth
because I'm in the fours now when I when
I feel pain it's not going like it's
it's and that was my last trip I was
like oh it'll never be the same I'm on
the other side of the coin hmm
There's No Going Back which makes me
live even more
and make me more present and and make me
adjust the internal thing because I
don't express a lot but now I have to
learn to and all this now because the
physical part is gone
that's really interesting because my
wife is 33 I'm 43. and she she was we we
did the podcast on Friday so this is the
guest episode comes out Wednesday we do
the Friday episodes and she was saying
she's like I know this is weird but like
sometimes I'll just be driving around
and I'm like almost like a narrator like
little did she know that was the day she
would die you know what I mean and I was
like
it look she's not my daughter I don't
I'm it's not like that you know we don't
mix the but I look at her like a younger
person I go like it's starting it's
what's happened to you is happening to
Val and when I was 33 that's when it
started to happen there's an ownership
of mortality there's an a recognition of
the pattern which by the way you're
right Rising sleeping yeah living dying
breathing in breathing out
um your heart contraction expansion
contraction expansion there's times I
liken it to menstruation as well as like
there's times when I'm very social when
a woman is ovulating she's very social
I've said this a million times but you
can tell a woman is ovulating by the
quality of her voice they sound like
Britney Spears they sound like
they're imitating the sound of an
ovulating woman that's what red lips
blush these are all indications that
they are fertile I I know that sounds no
I don't sound it makes all this stuff
makes sense because of how we respond to
those things that just goes all the way
back to the beginning of the same thing
with men by the way they're primitive
and the
you know the the part of Earth in the
Reverb and music we're still in this
saying we're on a trip right now Us in
this conversation but starting from the
you know what you said about us being
primitive and stuff and the universe
that's we came to earth like that or we
was we was evolved like that but these
sounds and vibrations are still a major
part of our life we just tuned them out
sure but like you said
um the with the period and stuff like
that uh these are true things that we we
don't even pay attention to that's right
and that's what psychedelics can help
you recognize I always remember Shane
Moss who's done a lot of DMT he goes I
can having all those experiences has
helped me realize that this is an
experience he's like this is a weird
trip and he goes you know there's
hierarchies and power and there's all
this weird exchange everything is like
agreed upon social currency whether it's
money good looks power health
crashes happen every Mountain years
crashes happen and
um in economics they built into the
system because it's how it's How it
balances yeah yeah so that yes we say oh
say finish it Thug so no I'm like this
is
this is stuff I guess because I came
from like such a different uneducated
background
and I'm like you I I'm blessed to have
some type of awareness to see those
things and make something of it like you
know so it's like man this stuff has
been here the whole time that's right we
just couldn't capitalize on on it in
fact it predates humans human beings are
the latest extension of the wave or the
tick I call this Tech I'm starting to
see us as Tech now Tech the original AI
to the way our mind works and if I had
statements say what our mind works I
don't know if you have a program before
zero one zero one or if this that yeah
if you touch this in this hot pulled
back if not continue sure you know
that's how you Pro that's how you code
right uh you know in layman's term so
and the way our body regenerates this is
my first trip experiencing that how a
body can regenerate itself and you know
how it it cleanses itself from things
um how you can stretch it and how
um how balanced it is for the most part
and if your body's out of alignment then
you have problems um whether it's uh
spiritually whether it is the food you
eat whether your bones structure is off
so I'm like uh and with Shane I had the
experience like oh we're we're the we're
a creation of something of some sort
um but us you know the theory like
growing up religion how we try to
emulate God we're now in that chair
we're having that experience of being
God and making creations of all our own
that's gonna be just as racist AI is
already proven that and Justice what do
you mean AI is racism yeah and you can
tell you you already had the GPT it's
like yeah I'm not talking to no Irishman
yeah like it's already end because
somebody put it in there but we were
programmed the same way as kids we
started empty just like Chad gbt and we
was filled with all type of things
itself right and we learned at the end
of the day the older you get that
mankind is the virus of the earth so you
don't think that chat gbt is gonna
figure that out right it's just gonna
have the power to do something you mean
like Terminator two style like you might
be like we could come together but even
Chad gbt gonna start fighting amongst
themselves for his own political uh
reasons
you support Trump you support Biden
Biden write a Manifesto in the style of
chat GPT becoming sentient and giving a
speech to other chat gpts man that'll be
that's gonna be a funny war but you you
did it for real yeah
gbt Civil War
yeah oh my gosh
given Epitaph for our fallen foes in the
style of the Civil War but it's it's a
beautiful thing to make these
discoveries and see these these patterns
civilization starting over with you know
with good intentions to get corrupt go
bad well it's interesting you said that
because I was just thinking I love what
you said AI
you know we're starting with the idea AI
will become racist or it will become
prejudiced well that's already done it
what does that mean like it
discriminated against somebody it was
the article that came out uh in the UK
that because you know they were they are
hiring and firing they allow y'all to
hire and fire people and it's all based
on their output based on something but
it's already have proven that it's been
discriminatory really yeah just like
when the app when the iPhone came out
with the face scan and all the Asian
people was opening the same phone the
different family was opening the same
phone oh I didn't know that oh man that
sounds like a hacker band that's real no
that was happening it was a video of it
and every Facebook they had to go back
and they had to go back and reprogram it
which yeah that shows like a certain
western-centric facial style which
obviously you know interesting yeah hard
to Riff on
to me is like I'm from the south so I'm
like
see
right I had the same I empathize with
the iPhone because I had the same
problem
well that's that's not
necessary like it's not a judgment if
you have a difficulty Discerning between
different people in a different race
right that's not actually primaries too
same race that's what I mean but it's
different from you I mean like if you
pick if you go if your brother called me
like I'm at the airport and you drive
you're gonna have to slow down to find
your brother at the airport
you're not going to be like oh you're
not gonna spot him out of everybody
Oh you mean because it's so many white
people yeah or so many people after a
while it just all blurs I lost my sister
in the Montclair store
[Laughter]
I lost my sister to my class store and I
asked the person I was like my sister
light skin with long hair
and it just happened to be a lot of
Asian people in Montclair store you know
and I lost it in there
I couldn't tell her skin is the same
complexion and everything she just
looked like every Montclair and I was
like I asked this person I went to the
uh the person somebody worked there and
I was like hey which one of these Asians
black
you know I mean that's what I asked they
are
too much oh my god did you find did they
know they were like yeah yeah they
should go right there and then they gave
you a glass of champagne I've been to a
Montclair store yeah but I didn't buy
nothing so they you know they always I'm
sorry hey I was look at what you got on
when you go in to judge whether you
should be in there or not I speaking of
different states I was in a fit of mania
and I was like I'm gonna go buy a
Montclair jacket and I did and I got it
it's like when you put a Christmas tree
in her car and then you ask how much it
is so I had the jacket some gorgeous
super model is checking me out she's
like it's eleven hundred dollars or
something like that and I was like but
it was too late yeah I paid I own it
already I didn't pay for the code I paid
to not be ashamed you know what I'm
saying like guilt that guilt it just
like I was like I couldn't be like oh
shut up
just a code
I've seen people do that with food send
food back they want to but they can't
it's too late once the food's on your
table that's your food no you're right
we was I was in Italy with my girl and
she didn't like the food
and uh his mom and pop restaurant
she didn't like it she didn't like it
and she wanted to send it back but she
couldn't because I mean and then the
lady was like you don't like because
it's it's Italy yeah so the lady like
like standing behind her you're wrong
yeah you don't like it yeah she's like
well you know whatever and she was like
give it here took the plate oh my God
she was trying to figure out how you
know she can get rid of the food and the
lady came out with another plate
and gave it to her and in mother fashion
stood over his shoulder and I watched
while laughing my girl eat this
slowly this food because it's something
child like remember when they put
vegetables on your plate yeah you didn't
want him like you can't leave the table
she watched she hovered like a hawk and
maybe yeah this is not this is Mom and
Pop you know what I mean this is
everything's riding on this yeah what
was it that she didn't like it I don't
know but I enjoyed I'm gonna do you
another one because there's something
when you're traveling you're in another
country I was in Uganda
and they we part of the trip was we
stayed with like a regular Uganda family
right in not as it wasn't a slum but it
was not if it was in America it'd be
Islam but it wasn't a Uganda slam it was
a rough neighborhood you know
impoverished neighborhood yeah I've been
in Cuba I know I know what you're saying
that's right yeah exactly very similar
and it was like I remember a couple
things about it one they only had power
three hours a day and it was like three
a.m to 6 a.m so that I'll get up from 3
A.M to 6 a.m and watch CNN I remember
that was like a weird thing so people
would set alarms get up and watch the
news for three hours go back to bed so
in the morning
excuse me they gave us I'm with this
other guy
this other white kid
um named Matt and they gave us Frosted
Flakes but the box was really really old
the bag was new but the box it was the
150th time they've used this box like
the box was a special box and the bag
was new and I'm bored I'm like that's
very nice they got us Frosted Flakes and
the milk they gave us was like clearly
just milked from McDonald's yeah it was
a goat or something and it had a film on
it that you could have walked on
and I'm thinking about this was my
church group I'm thinking about all the
cultural training they gave us you can
like I'm telling you this was like a
poor family and they're giving us the
best of the best so I'm pouring I'm
trying to I don't want the skin to slip
out like a two-pack so I'm just trying
to get the liquid and I'm eating it and
then they pass it to Matt and he goes
I'm good
[Laughter]
stuff do so your your girl was eating
pasta
slurping it up real slow and I'm
laughing she like and she got the look
of her face Stone Cold and I'm done
laughing amazing I got footage of it but
I made it publicly shared but uh but
what happened with my suit when I went
to see my dad because my dad was
schizophrenic
is he not anymore no no or is he what is
it why was he's cured yeah like really
yeah I didn't forgive my ignorance I
didn't know you could cure schizophrenia
oh well that's the trade in the universe
like humans can treat it but the
universe can cure God can cure it is
that what happened yeah tell me
everything he died
[Laughter]
that's the internet clip chop it up
no one's ever called it out that's the
internet clip oh man you just walked
into that one I sure did
um
oh my God I remember because it was a
point I was afraid of like I thought he
would kill people killed me of course
yeah so I remember me of course because
when you see an unhoused person that's
unstable everybody worries that this is
going to go to a violent yes it's not
just yeah and um so you're worried that
about your own yeah yeah yeah yeah
um he was still living both parents at
one point but he was living at the time
and I didn't see him in seven years but
I remember from childhood how good of a
parent he was so I was like I want to
tell him thank you so we went to see him
and I got in a car and like he was
sitting there he was in the hood and he
had on no shirt a skull cap and jogging
pants I told this story before and he
just out there
and I'm like back the car in if
something go wrong take off so I'm I'm
the paranoid person yeah
yeah we backed it in that's like the car
equivalent of always have your back to
the wall in a restaurant yeah I mean I
do that too you know I mean so
yeah long story short this time's in
your story I go he like what's up I
ain't seen it right and I hugged them
and it was so uncomfortable because they
have on those shirts and I was like you
shouldn't hook you should be like a
sporting event like winning a
championship the hug somebody with no
shirt on really
he's bigger than me like six six one six
two like 200 some pounds and I'm like if
he just goes into a squeeze I'm like
done for I'm like locked in
all this going through my mind like an
anaconda you mean yeah and uh but he
would only do that because he was having
an unstable moment
you don't know yeah I don't know you
know some people like hug you like we
didn't I didn't really hug growing up
some people hug you hard yeah and you
still like what's going on yeah yeah but
get to the point of it he saw my sister
and he was like hey what's going on and
my sister was just like hey good to see
you again and I was like oh I should
have did that yeah your frosted flakes
go that's the Frosted Flakes thing you
know you went for the shake
good to see you Dad yeah and that that's
what a handshake is well we got two
different dads so okay yeah my mom
blessed us with
you got two yeah you gotta variety
variety well it's like I was like the
beauty of it is
you can't get jealous that your dad
spent more time with you than right me
because different dads and we didn't
spend time with none of our fathers
it's kind of like when someone's a
different religion I remember like when
I had a friend who was let's say they
were Jewish I'd be like I don't care
about your God I just care about Jesus
yeah there's kind of a relief to it it's
a relief oh I'm glad you got to hang out
with Jesus I'll be over here that way
you know when you talk [__] you talk
about when we talk we didn't talk about
these mothers we talked about each other
dad of course that's when your day ain't
got no hands leave that's why your dad
ain't got no that's why your dad
you know all that [__] I mean but when
my dad died my sister was at the funeral
and they did the whole
flag folding because he was in the Navy
and they they was like on behalf of uh
president Trump we giving this flag to
you and I remember looking out the side
of my eye and somebody was just like
don't don't do it I just took the flag
you almost sided with like not wanting
something for president I almost said
something but he's just like they know
how I am and then um I remember looking
back at my sister she wiping her eyes as
they like you know dismiss everybody
cranking their bodies now and she was
crying and I looked at her and I was
like
my dad funeral was better than your
dad's funeral
and she was like
it was [__] you oh my God
how did he die here's another ignorant
question I guess I've never talked to
too many I haven't talked to too many
people well schizophrenia
property of the state
and he was doing dialysis like
liver five times a week yeah because he
was an addict for a long time also
um what was he addicted to uh crack and
um and uh he should smoke weed when he
was young which could be a trigger for
schizophrenia yeah if you do it at a
teenage is crack I wonder if there's
something that helps no I'm not saying
helps well self-medication you don't for
me being ignorant to it in the community
we're ignorant towards mental health in
general yeah
um
I I realized that he was probably self
when I say helps I don't mean helps I
mean like no yeah it's it's something
with ADD you sometimes go towards the
uppers yeah for a similar thing that's
all I meant so in my my because he would
stop cold turkey so
um
but I think it was a thing of it was in
a tough position because with medication
abuse paranoid you think people trying
to kill you yeah so yeah he wouldn't
take his medication but he did they just
end up heavily sedating him and I think
it was an issue with his body not being
able to take it
but it was better than him being in the
state that vegetable State and always
trying to figure out how can I get out
of this while people poison them so to
me this is a more peaceful
yeah yeah and how like some of the
family members took it because the
paranoia that's their reality it's again
I'm not trying to but you don't have to
be I had a bad trip that made me
experience and let me know what he went
through that's what I was gonna say yeah
there's certain trip drug experiences
that let you know
like this is going to sound silly but I
remember one of the first times I got
Paranoid on on weed I was I was like but
this is real and then I realized I was
like oh you wouldn't be paranoid if you
didn't think it was real like your
belief in it is what makes it paranoia
you think when you're not stoned and
you're like well if I got stoned I just
realized I was paranoid but you believe
it and that's what makes it what it is
or or it would just be a thought yeah
but then you actually give in to the
thought and think people are following
you or you are going to explode or if
you stop breathing you're gonna die
there's so many there's so much yours it
was so many things tied tied into
society pattern wise that I saw
um when it came to trauma and what you
know my culture
came up in or come from that's not
healed which it's all experience in this
country yeah that's different to me than
other black people I met who are a
little bit more affluent who don't have
those traumatic things that they still
living with so I was you mean Collective
drama coming through and through slavery
of course those those things and being
paranoid of society
and and
um how we move through Society or how we
some people don't put money in the bank
still because of the right land and
stuff that was stolen from all that
right stuff that I'm like oh this is
bigger than this is not what we think it
is this is innately
mras and all DNA but it's
you know because my African friends
don't have it
it's a slavery thing this is a thing
yeah you know that family is different
sometimes I feel like you tell me it's
just crossed my mind they use whenever
there's black people in commercials
they're like like the skeptical black
guy I'm like I feel like they're
manipulating like the the distrust that
you're talking about like I'm not gonna
put my money in the bank I'm not gonna
do this I'm not going to do that but I
will drink Pepsi you know what I mean
like there's something going on there
does that make any sense well is it part
of it is that and it's also like Target
marketing too because it's like why the
[__] they keep playing
Dancing Yeah and song in this commercial
you know what I mean right right and
you're like that's messed up and then
you with your homeboy and y'all singing
a commercial and [__] you know right
right
um so it's it's uh but Rhythm you know
from coming from spiritual person like
again these these rhythms and these
tones
or how we communicated
you know uh back in the day just like
how's NATO suit with drum circles and
stuff yeah yeah so it's just built into
the fabric of us that's what I mean is
we're exploiting
advertising will explode whatever it
needs to exploit to get a message to
stick even if it is cultural Trauma from
everybody though no yeah yeah yeah but
that's part of the yeah my mom is a
first generation Lithuanian she fled
World War II I see it in advertising too
a stereotypical version of my mom being
like Frugal or like or finding a deal
and that goes back to a memory of a time
where it was hard for her to find food
you know what I mean yeah and they're
like we got you Safeway like Albertsons
we got like they're they're I'm not
saying it's evil it would almost be
stupid to not
there's no morals maybe not and that
there's no morals in once you realize
was with business or capitalism
sometimes there's no morals in it right
right so if somebody gets shot by the
cops
a black person then it's like oh we
gotta we gotta hire black people and we
gotta do we gotta get it to charity and
we gotta do this thing but it's like
Clark you get once you get older you
realize the pattern because you you live
through 91 the doctor I'm in a Rodney
King situation you live through these
rights and stuff and you see the same
thing happening
you know I mean I remember
um
when fox in 90 if you really pay
attention what's going on and I'm saying
it as a black guy who works in TV and
film now after the right after riots and
stuff happening in roles that might not
have been for black people
you mean after Rodney King after uh the
um George Floyd uh the latest one but I
remember after Rodney King that's when
Fox you know Fox was a new network and
you had a Living Color you had Martin
you had all these black shows that built
the Fox network after running yeah right
at 91 yeah and you saw black movies and
stuff being made and it went on for like
five years and then it went it went dry
you're seeing that pattern and seeing
when it happened before in society with
Muhammad Ali and and Jim Jim uh Jim
Brown and all those guys Malcolm and
everything that happened politically and
black people had that stuff in them it
went quiet so there's a flare-up it's a
flat because it's like a creative yeah
oh it's because it's not not to do the
right thing but because it's profitable
it's it's been yeah in this so soccer is
always nothing really it gotten better
but it hasn't really changed hmm
yeah that's that's really really
interesting I feel silly taking a break
for the ads but we'll be right back we
got to take you on it
speaking of you know
hit it
if I do a podcast
[Laughter]
no I do before we do I'm going to
acknowledge there's no good time in
conversations about capitalism and
morality and uh you're saying these
things flare up because it's profitable
and I'm like we'll be right back right
back after these ads it's not the first
time it's happened on the Rama Yousef
episode we were having this really deep
conversation about the evils of
capitalism and we're like we'll be right
back but you know what Katie's not free
we'll be right back
hey there weirdos this episode is
brought To Us by our friends at Sunday's
food for dogs this is hands down the
easiest dog food I've ever had for Brody
because you don't need to refrigerate it
it's also the highest quality dog food
I've ever had for Brody it is also
incredibly incredibly high quality and
easy and it's his favorite that's number
three Brody flips out for Sunday's food
for dogs why why it tastes incredible
it's air dried dog food made from a
short list of human grade ingredients
you can tell just by looking at it this
is simple simple dog food done right
right it was co-founded by Dr Tori a
practicing veterinarian it contains 90
Meat 10 vegetables and zero percent
synthetic nutrients besides USDA beef
and all natural chicken you'll find
Digest festive AIDS like pumpkin Ginger
plus disease fighting antioxidants dog
parents report noticeable Health
improvements in their pups we can attest
to that his energy is through the roof
he's a happy happy boy especially when
I'm boring him up all of this stuff it's
softer fur fresher breath my favorite
better poops let's be real what you feed
your dog has an impact on how those
walks go and Sundays keeps it tight
keeps it tight as well as more energy
Brody flips for this stuff we've tried
in the past to get him like uh natural
shorter list ingredients dog food but it
always ended up overflowing out of our
kitchen it was shipped to us in
cumbersome packages with dry ice and all
this waste Sundays is like having a box
of cereal in your pantry it's that
simple you take it out it's air dried
you don't have to refrigerate it you
don't have to keep it cold you just keep
it in the pantry pour it in the bowl
close it back up just like a box of
cereal but it's high high quality May
makes him feel great and from the looks
of it it tastes incredible unlike other
fresh dog food Sundaes is zero prep zero
mess zero stress shelf stable makes it
easy to feed your pup top quality food
and every order ships right to your door
so you'll never worry about running out
of dog food again which frankly used to
happen to us I love having it on a
recurring schedule because one thing you
can count on your dog's gonna eat so get
a recurring schedule going Sundays cost
40 percent less than other Healthy dog
food brands because Sundays doesn't
waste money shipping Frozen packages
instead they instead they spend on what
matters sourcing the best all natural
ingredients for your pup so we worked
out a special deal for our dog loving
weirdos get 35 off your first order
that's almost half off 35 percent
off your first order off Sundays go to
Sundays for dogs.com weird or use code
weird at checkout that's
s-u-n-d-a-y-s-f-o-r-d-o-g-s.com forward
slash weird get 35 off your first order
show some love and support for your dog
show some love and support for this show
upgrade your pup to Sundays and feel
good about the food you feed your dog
let's get back to the episode you'll
also notice one quick shout out we're
drinking Nirvana Water Nirvana
watersciences.com if you want to try the
water that we're drinking in every
episode that supports lean muscle
development improves muscle performance
and Mobility reduces muscle soreness and
boosts recovery time post exercise all
because of their proprietary my hmb
clear formulation that's been studied
for the past three decades by scientists
Physicians and leaders in the medical
field go to Nirvana watersciences.com
use promo code P20 for 20 off 20 all
right let's get back to Byron Bowers
okay we're back
okay yeah so it's interesting I don't
exactly know if I understand completely
I remember after 9. tell me
it's a black person in the room too
that's what I'm learning what do you
mean so every time it's it's something
usually when it's like an offensive ad
or when Gucci come up with the shirt
with big lips it's probably a black
person in the room that's like
you mean when they come up with the
product yeah
because because what I'm learning
because I'm in in some of the back rooms
now just because I say something don't
mean it's for all black people I'm from
I'm a certain demographic of course
you're uneducated whatever but then it's
it's somebody who parents went to
grandparents went to college and they
don't stand for none of this stuff I
stand for and we're the same you know
race you know I mean right they might be
Dr King Fanatics and I'm more like trap
music right
so and I'm from the city to go back we
said earlier where it's mostly black
so you see the breakdown with even
within the culture right right well it's
absurd to think that anybody is the
spokesperson but what you're saying so
something questionable isn't being
floated around when there's one black
person there you do feel you see it at
comedy shows too yeah all the black
guy's laughing so that means that the
little person's laughing or the guy in
the wheelchair is laughing like we still
have that pack mentality where we're
like well there's a representative of
all of them here you representing all of
them today right but hey it goes for
Disabilities as well yeah like if I
remember watching somebody going doing a
lot of
wheelchair stuff but there was a guy in
a wheelchair laughing everybody was just
like yeah therefore this is fine but
that's what I found me found funny and
when people like oh you edgy because I'm
like you know you you do got the black
person at the wheelchair who get
discriminated against
you know what I mean uh and then they
gotta you know do that so or the per the
the
and in my mind I I play with that world
like the person that's deaf but then
this person the street deaf and I
remember the first time I saw a gang uh
person sign to another game person and I
was like it looked like silence but they
was talking to each other across the
street where you from from here this is
what said I claim but it looked like of
course sign language so and I'm in I'm
in um
Israel Tel Aviv and they doing sign
language and I'm like hey is it is this
Hebrew
is this Hebrew and he's like no sign
language is one language and I'm like uh
how that don't make sense to me but I
play with that because in my mind it's
still like some Street vernacular in in
sign language and sign language well
there's got to be some overlap it's like
I remember I went to Venezuela when I
was a kid
the word for in yanamami the yanamami
Indians the word for no is Ma I'm like
of course this is going to be even
though we share No ancestors it's not an
indo-germanic language
your word for no is going to be short in
the same way
in Sign Language whether it's a street
sign language or American Sign Language
or whatever
there are certain words you're going to
have to say a lot and it's probably
going to look something like this no but
I always wonder what the n-word version
of that that's me uh I did a joke in
sign language you gotta spell it there's
no sign for that well I sat at this
table I was at an award show and I sat
at the table with the sign language
people so that's when I was the mother
because they were like
you can't small talk
what do you mean you can't be like hey
what's going on you know I'm in an
awards with a round table sure and they
blah blah blah blah and you just like
you know putting butter on your bread
and you look you like this is all you
really you like goofy this you can't
even wave properly you gotta you don't
even take it into consideration you know
I mean peas you know yeah so I'm like oh
man
like I'm the only black dude at the
table and I don't know sign language so
that's what my thought I wonder what the
word for inward is at the table uh
because you know I would get glances and
I'm like you know does this mean
anywhere like when they do like this uh
whatever so that's my paranoia but I had
fun with it also
because I'm like to them
to them
I'd be like who put this mother here
he ain't one of us
and I jumped in both both heads you know
I mean if that makes sense
oh you're gonna say you're on stage and
you'd say it if there was something
translating you you would see well I was
looking at somebody translate it was
about inclusion it was an inclusion
person giving a speech so they had
somebody signing that and I remember
they was like the straights and the gays
and they did this that means gay so
that's what triggered my world I wonder
what the n-word is because I was like
can they still say can they still
and I told her to tell the story I'll
have to retire certain things that means
gay you probably like you have to this
ain't that long ago so I was like we're
doing a limp wrist gesture which by the
way is what a lot of old men in Boston
do for gay that's what we thought like
is that still the word that's what made
in this in the story I tell that's what
makes it like trigger that like I wonder
what the N word is if this still means
yeah yeah because that always had meant
and I was like did we take that from
sign language or was that did they take
that from us yeah because that's a
church way of saying like right you know
if you grew up in church or something
you'd be like hey don't he kind of like
right you know what I mean which what
I'd like to know anthropologically all
of that why a limp wrist like what does
it mean to have like a a firm upright
strong wrist and this is like a weak is
that what it is
I know we're like well that's kind of
effeminate it's kind of like if you're
like kind of like dainty like that or
whatever you want to say why why is that
a sign why is that what your body does
when you are embodying
a female like a feminine presence or
whatever it might be I guess because all
of the
if you observing
doing a certain time I don't know when
signing was born
and if it was born in like the 80s or
something that's kind of late no it was
oh okay yeah well it was like go back to
like VC or something I don't know I'd
like to know but I know and There Will
Be Blood as Sun Goes deaf it's 1898 and
they teach him something oh okay so all
right oh it's definitely been around for
but I guess the point I'm making is uh I
guess from observation they saw like a
lot of gay people at that time oh
interesting I feel like what they were
considered what they were consider right
dandies they'd be like look at this
Dandy on his big wheel bicycle and it
was limp press and they like yeah got it
and then and then the straights would
suddenly be like
what was it like having a dad with
schizophrenia
man
um
at the time at the time it was bad like
when you're going through a bad trip you
don't know what's going on it's
different than the drug thing happened
um
if I would it could have been worse if I
would have known earlier
I mean it could have been easy if I was
known earlier but they just like oh you
know how he is Daddy was that he was Ill
yeah well you know you know it's nothing
that was talked about or the scientific
stuff wasn't right
talked about is is a thing of like
how did it manifest what were you how
did you know the first time I
experienced something was when
we was walking in the house and he was
like man yo
you know uh these girls saying I did all
type of stuff to her and and
um I heard you told told the police I
did something to it but I didn't I
didn't hit her I just grabbed it like
this and he grabbed me by my shirt and
like like that and
um he was like it's all good I don't
blame you you don't you didn't know what
was going on
oh and none of this had happened I don't
know what are you talking about yeah
um but he was like um
you could uh he was like he was like
they can come for me I got some form and
then he took the ceiling
top like the the the thing in the Attic
or whatever and he pulled out two Uzis
oh my God
and um
and then I was just like all right
basically I went and ate some Frosted
Flakes
um but and I've told my grandfather
uh Granddad put on some clothes I got
something that's not I was like
put your dick away
but my grandfather I don't think you
should see your dad for a while
but we still didn't fully get explained
what was going on right it would have
been better if someone was like your dad
is ill there's some sickness happening
and then the stories come stories make
sense because my dad was taking a
shooting
one time he was what taking a shooting
to shoot rifles uh and my grandma was
like don't don't get in the car with him
don't you get in there and we was all
like man why Grandma tripping we just
going to shoot right shoot cans we want
to go shouldn't have been in the house
all day but looking back is like
you know
you were going shooting with an unstable
yeah and he got kicked out of the mall
for pulling two two blocks out on uh
some of his old co-workers who um
he thought was talking trash about him
something he had done manufactured like
it wasn't not that it makes sense if it
was happening but it wasn't happening I
don't know because I don't
when you grow up with these stories you
think it's real you didn't know he
didn't know he didn't know but I don't I
don't know so imagine if he don't if
your pops is like man they and it's so
in line with what's going on in the
world
a white lady said something to me they
don't fire me at the job these white
boys and like he he lived he was one
black dude who lives in the in the white
neighborhood with when two people had to
work to pay for what he could pay for on
his own because he was good with money
and stuff and that came with his own
stresses you know I mean uh in the 80s
so uh especially in a town where you're
doing better than everybody like it's
stuff that doesn't actually make you
paranoid anyway right
so it just it just put a blur on
everything because you like was that
real
yeah it's a black man living in Los
Feliz
you know I mean you go through those you
go through the similar things what do
you mean
um when security follow you around the
neighborhood or oh really yeah
um
you come home at night somebody's
trailing you you know or those things so
it's just natural this is natural Hood
stuff anyway so it blurred the lines
between them people like oh you can't
trust women they got their money
hmm
yeah it was like an exaggeration like
like my therapist said you know I always
remember this he goes paranoid people
are right you know like if you're
paranoid you're correct like if you
think your heart might stop or or you
know I always think it's interesting
that not to put Darkness out in the
world but like when I'm at the airport
I'm never worried you get on the plane
and then you might worry that the plane
might crash but it's like but if you're
at an airport you're where a plane would
crash you know what I mean like but we
don't really think about that but a
paranoid person does and they're correct
like you there is a higher chance that
something might happen while you're at
the airport but you tend to not worry no
I worry because the Atlanta airport
shooting
well that too right yeah and uh at any
moment I'm like just like how your girl
said like this was the day
I have to be driving down the street
like at any moment a bullet can hit
right well that's true because true
because and it's environmental I used to
walk home from school like that yeah
right like I'm trying to do the right
thing at any moment some a random uh
shootout can happen right somewhere far
and you in the woods and bullet can hit
you right you know so but to finish my
therapist point he's like you that's
true yeah but you can't let it rule your
life well it did for a while right ruled
my life it doesn't seem like it is I
want to step on cracks because I hurt my
mama back I was superstitious and
religious growing up so it was super
like yeah focused so it's definitely a
lot of stuff like that you know what
were your superstitions I mean don't put
hats on the bed don't put purse on the
floor
don't put don't put a woman purse on the
floor because
um you know make a broke is that a thing
yeah that's the super City I didn't put
that one we we broke
I'll never put your bag on the floor we
still broke we haven't been kicked out
of our house you know what I mean all
this stuff
yeah because you're not
you don't learn about financial literacy
you know what I mean you learn about
don't put a person put your purse on the
floor and learn to take a book out there
[__] and learn how to save ten
percent of everything
but um so you were religious and I
answered everything because you saw
y'all everything people believe you tell
you know if you put a hat on the bed
somebody to die that's it I didn't know
that yeah there's like certain stuff
like that if you if you eat if you wash
your clothes on the last Sunday of the
you know of the month
somebody could die it's like a little
stuff like that interesting yeah see
we're back at the bullet or the airport
dangers or whatever we're all doing our
best to live in a world that is
constantly changing so those things give
the
you know we do it in a fancy way too you
can look at data like certain type of
scientific data and be like this gives
me Comfort I'm not saying science is
superstition I'm just saying no study is
perfect yeah how many times does a study
come out and they're like well they
weren't studying this factor to this
fact or this fact but [__] that when it
comes out especially if it confirms our
bias we take a lot of comfort in it I'm
going to say that's that's just a
different Echelon of don't put a hat on
a bed it's just a way of feeling like
you have control like your bit about
paper straws I want to feel like I have
control I know that 99 of plastic waste
in the ocean is from commercial fishing
but I'm going to stop using straws
because it gives me the illusion of
contribution because and then I can kind
of like quiet down the voices that's
another hat on a bench and just like my
cousin they trying to give them 10 years
over this little bag over a pound of
weed yeah
knowing that the government gets the
stuffing
yeah in the cartel these are billion
dollars this is a billion dollar
business this ain't right right you know
so it's the same with the straws to me
so that's the parallels of it and as
well as the the homelessness
which my dad were one of the streets
yeah that's all these things tie in but
it took the reason to realize a lot of
those people running the streets are
mentally yeah ill right right
well that's what we had in the 80s you'd
call a home I didn't but my dad didn't
but some people would call homeless
people bums because that was a way of
saying these are lazy people these are
non-productive people now it gets a lot
more complicated when you go like these
are mentally ill people or it's it's
would rather be ignorant and clear-cut
and go and we're back at racism or
whatever uh social economics because
yeah
the thing of me touching the turtle
yeah in yourself which is which is
could be way more dangerous than
touching a homeless person's hand
[Music]
um but just as the same texture as
touching a crackhead's hand
which I found way more nasty than
touching a sea turtle like I took
chances on the sea turtle right right
versus like feeling a crackhead which is
like
you know what I mean where what religion
were you raised did you say Baptist
Baptist and where are you at now we're
in the last 20 minutes or so here we
always talk about the meaning of life
you seem like you have an interesting
one we're talking about waves this is
this is a world view this is a thought
system
I'm curious what you make
of reality if you have a story that you
tell about it some sort of framework for
it I believe nature law of a man man's
law nature over man's yeah what does
that mean
um
like if a lion is hungry is going to eat
like for man's that hungry he would do
something to his own brother hmm you
know the idea that we're like three
meals away from chaos chaos but then you
know if it if it rains you live on the
muddy Hill it's gonna slide don't care
how much money you got or nothing or
right we drive fancy cars through the
canes if you mess up you're going over
right it don't carry your race right
like Nature's just don't care about
certain things right and to me that
comes first the man ability to kill like
some people I never kill but you don't
know because you know I've been pushed
there before so I always have that that
nature will right supersede what is
illegal or not right you know there's a
humility to that too yeah it's a
privilege to say I would never do this
or this is basically what you're saying
is I've never been pushed to do this
this or this or this yeah or it's not
it's not in me but oh it's of course
yeah there's uh Primal things happening
yeah so that's what I mean like and
people will break the man's break man's
law if if it's natural
if it's some natural tool right
pedophilia is that it's all that is
breaking Nature's law yeah no this is
this is not this is my Nature's law it's
illegal for me to do to do this
so I gotta but I cannot not do it and I
just use that one thing that's what you
mean that's what breaking I mean huh
that's what that's what breaking man's
law is yeah your net your nature or your
natural thing takes over that so is
murder murder is a version of that yeah
right and most other things still in the
eat is a verse yeah I mentioned all the
time but uh I read the book tribe and
they talk about like the biggest law you
could break was hoarding or or stealing
more than is your share taking more food
than as you share and they're like uh
there's a spider
tiny one look at you
cool
cool yeah cause I don't know the type of
spider I always had to see before I yeah
that was cool though yeah relaxed
you looked more relaxed yes that was
just like yo here gunshots that's when
you don't panic
Don't Panic yeah why because you got to
know you don't know you got to figure
out where it's coming from there's a lot
of things you gotta figure out before
you move or you're gonna run in the
direction of the thing right so you you
you know outside of anger is learning
how to tame the that the fear but we do
that I knew that we're driving anyway
yeah yeah yeah
you feel this adrenaline and you use you
you you cycle it back through so it's
calm well the the fear and stuff is you
being present that's why I say if I'm
not nervous I'm not
there's something wrong wrong with me
with not being nervous yeah whether I'm
about to drive or whether um like I see
why people do these activities now
because if one it helps you tame your
nerves but you use your nerves because
it makes you more alert that's right
people at still 20 plus years in stand
up they're like do you get nervous and
I'm like I know it's not my line but I
go I'm nervous when I'm not nervous
that's the scary part if you're too calm
you do it right if I'm like feeling
really funny from like backstage and I'm
just being real funny I'm like it's
that's the wrong energy it has to be
this like question yeah like am I funny
can I do this in the in the right way
and then you go out and there's there's
a there's a bout now now something's
happening like you're especially in a
boxing ring that's that's the feeling
you don't want to go out being like I'm
the king of the world I'm the Champion
necessarily that's how I felt but then
so much went wrong I said what's up the
laugh might fell out the the uh really
covet killed 80 of my audience so it's
people there for my childhood and even
though I talked because they're not used
to hearing me talk so all the at the end
when I thought everybody would be like
man that was so dope it was like man I'm
proud of you
yeah because without everything I went
through because they was like I didn't
even know he didn't talk when he was
little or
you know
um it was guys that was like he ain't
funny why are we going to this wow well
that's your hometown thing yeah that's
what I'm saying so it ended up being the
people that needed you know spiritually
needed to be there of course but it
wasn't necessarily people being a
spiritual I love that people are putting
their hands up because I oh yeah I've
been to black church oh yeah this is
good they were also giving you a wider
vocabulary of responses there was like
and like like people were and you could
hear all that and I was like this is
really good you did something very human
something real what sound I was like we
got to get all of those responses you
can tell yeah because you can smooth
those out in post some people might take
them out but you had a very real special
it's it's admirable it's really special
thank you man so let me ask you this do
you think when you die it's over
you talk to your dad you have a
relationship after they're gone now
here's the thing
in this problem with my Social Media
stuff this is my life is my
of uh VR yeah this is the journey so so
me my soul is here to do all type of
things so yeah maybe just like you take
off Oculus you go back to doing stuff
like when you die yeah so to me it's
like okay this thing is over the the
this is this was fun it's like playing a
video game all right yeah for better for
worse you know we're here for a journey
I tell people it's like if you play
Mario and you missed the jump first jump
what happened
you come back you come back right yeah
that's the lesson if you don't get the
first jump you ain't gonna get to the
next thing right so I learned that we
sometimes you see people that keep
bumping their head on the same thing
when it's time you get to leave this
place this world but until then you
gotta learn to get over the jumps or you
you still another world you got to go
through yeah the princess is in another
castle Yeah so I think it's something
else man but I realize you know having
my dad die in my arms which is such a
spiritual thing than having die as my
dad which is the worst thing that I can
experience uh what do you mean he died
in your arms which was a spiritual thing
he died in my arms I felt him go through
my body and I was able to communicate
with him his Spirit yeah
like I felt it before the machines knew
which is crazy and then I had to tell
everybody
it's like a weird tingly it's like a
sharp tingle
um and it started in my hands like you
know how your your feet and stuff like
go to sleep but then they get stronger
and stronger and then it just moved up
my body and like a burning uh uh tingle
you know I mean and I'm there by his
bedside and I'm just like
it's like it still is that hiss right
now because you can't
tell nobody because you ain't
experiencing this thing and you know
what it is it's a heat
it's a heat that goes up and then it
just it's just
gone and it like trailed out yeah but
yeah I wasn't
angry it's very peaceful it was one of
the most peaceful outside of being on
shrooms is one of the most peaceful
Stillness
how is his energy his energy went
through he was his well he came out of a
coma when I was there he coded five
times and it's crazy because I was
coming I was doing press for this movie
I was in at Tiff at Toronto Film
Festival and I landed and my cousin
called and was like hey he cold it five
times and uh they not gonna they're not
gonna bring him back and I asked my girl
what that means his heart stopped
so we went we came back close eight went
back to the airport went to Georgia
drove three hours in the night and got
there like two o'clock in the morning
wow and when I got there he was asleep
you know uh and then he saw me in his
eyes open then he started moving towards
me and
I was like I don't know if he thought
you know he wanted to give me a hug or
he wanted to choke choke me so that
stuff is still there right if you're
normal like he thought I was there to
kill him like that was the that was the
paranoia part yeah
um and uh
I remember he couldn't talk because he
had a tubes breathing but I remember
looking into his soul
and telling him no need to apologize for
nothing you were great
you know he was balancing something that
was out of your hands and I'ma I'm gonna
take what you've done as far as I can
take it I'm gonna take the flag on the
planet somewhere as far as as uh as I
can for the next you know for the next
person
and you know
um
when he did pass I realized
you know how you at the theme park and
it's a person in front of you on this
single single person in front of you on
a roller coaster and he gets on
and I'm like looking and there's nobody
behind me
and I'm next
because I have no kids and I was like oh
[__]
and that's like one of the realest
feelings ever you know I mean they're
your next to that I'm the I'm the last
yeah Bowers and I'm next cause my
grandfather happened to say wait I was
the last person my grandfather saw
cause I'm the Third
so I'm the remaining of this the
bloodline too so my grandfather came out
of coma in 96. and my mother told me to
tell them by and this was all new to me
and he died when I left he died but he
came out of his coma to see me wow and
she's like tell him you love him and
everything so it was experience I
experienced that twice
so let's feel good to feel you're worth
leaving a coma well that and be able to
have this experience and and bring this
closure that a lot of people don't have
right so we shooting this opening we on
shrooms
like we get a call somebody died and
it's bad it's bad right
and we still taking them we filming and
then
that night
the snowstorm happened in the middle of
the desert and I'm hugging my girl we
crying
and I'm like it's a storm coming
it's 20 20 uh 2021 or something like
that it's a storm coming I can I don't
know what it is but it's coming and you
can you can see the haze coming all the
way and it's the snow is packed
and um
I remember like saying like Earth is
dying like everybody's sleep now like
Earth is dying I'm dying you need help
ask for help
you can't go through this alone all
these things like my health will never
be the same and like the trip is getting
bad
and I had my first anxiety attack
because I'm breathing and I can't
control my breath and I'm like breathing
like my dad on the breathing machine
because when he died it was just his
body was just limp and it was like that
and I'm trying to get in rhythm with
this breathing machine
and I look up and I'm like my girl like
you're okay she's sleeping like I'm
dying I'm dying and I look and I see
death
and like a black hoodie and with white
behind them and I look into it and it's
me
looking at my dad because I wore a black
hoodie with the hood up hmm
and to me this is to me the worst way to
die is in a hospital bed to me
but I'm going through that death
and I experienced the loss I experienced
was another one of the worst things that
experienced me so in that trip I
experienced two of my worst fears
and I went through this whole thing and
I and I let go what you have to do in
life right and everything went steel and
quiet
and I look at my cousin asleep who I
love my girls right here is peacefully
asleep the dog is here peacefully sleep
my girl best friend upstairs was all
family
and
I grabbed my phone
and I wrote
I died and broke up rich
[Laughter]
I'm in the deserts of fire going it's
glass everywhere it's a beautiful view
of the snow
and because that the family your loved
ones are there that's like the
wealthiest thing to me yeah yeah so wow
yeah
so that's that that's the part of
opening you then that you didn't yeah
you didn't see from your special because
we did this room like we did shrooms for
real yeah I was gonna ask that's crazy
so with your dad passing through you
that seems just lend itself to Spirit
life continuing us being Souls yeah
bodies all that
yeah I was on I made love to my lady one
time we was in London
and I remember going to the bathroom and
I was peeing
and I was like man my dad would be proud
of me because he had a lot of women
from that and uh I was thinking about
him and the French doors open
and I was like uh
I was like come on man
because you don't want to ever get them
thoughts to me that's like every black
person in a horror movie like not trying
to be scared but he's starting to get
scared he's like man come on man y'all
tripping man you know when I went and
clowned in bed but I remember my
grandfather my grandfather told me he
was mad one time my dad walked in on my
grandmother while he's trying to have
said he just looked over and was like
what y'all doing
the doors open like all that stuff came
back to me and I was like
yeah like come on man and I got in the
bed I remember putting the cover up with
my head have you ever almost died
yeah like eight nine times yeah really I
drowned once you drowned I drowned I was
playing about the pool I had to be like
I think probably four years old
and I drowned and I saw
you know you know how the pool look that
beautiful blue and that little light was
like the last thing I saw and I woke up
and somebody had me in their hands uh
and they've given me to my to my mom wow
um that's one time I fell off a swing a
rusty swing set and laying on my neck
and it was stuck and I couldn't breathe
and I was like trying to get help but I
couldn't you know explain and somehow it
popped back oh my god
um
various stuff like that car accidents
uh yikes yeah and I'm now I'm nervous
because it's at least about eight times
yeah most people just they're like no or
they have one no this is like and I'm
like I don't know how many more of these
I have either you know to come out and
unscathed
um but you get bullet time there's been
times I've been in the car and like
one time a truck was a semi was merging
and I was in a little Ford Focus and it
didn't see me and it got dark it started
to blow all the light and it got dark
and I just let go
uh uh it was over like I'm in the call
of myself and I tried to like like punch
it and it didn't have enough power and I
just let go in the truck
just merged and the car somehow slowed
down enough
to where I was just like it just came
and I was just hollered and I just
downshifted and then got over whoa
bullet time bullet that one but that one
bulletin I know I was in my sister car
and a car something happened with cars a
car swerved like this and then I threw
it in neutral and then just got up and
now I never respected her legit until
then and I was like I was like this is a
solid car
Volkswagen yeah car the people yeah car
the people hey by the way to finish that
point before Hitler's addresses they
would play those Unholy frequencies that
are really unpleasant and then when he
started to speak beneath the speech
they'd play pleasing tones
you know what I'm saying so you you turn
it on he's like he's gonna talk at 11.
you turn on at 10 55 and relax
and it'd come on and be like and
underneath it'd be like
wow is that crazy that's brilliant
right sometimes I worry you know how
they're like we're gonna give the whole
world free internet I'm like it's a
radio man yeah it's a free radio and but
that's the thing with those scientists
back then for better for worse man they
not they really knock some stuff out
they got what they got they knocked some
stuff out between tinkering with people
and the weird serums and the weapons and
the cars and right the radio and all
these new discoveries that they were
doing at the time you know not
you know for better for worse that's
kind of what happens when you
you deal with you know I had a bad my
first bad trip I experienced what it's
like to lose love at such a massive
scale that I wanted power
oh wow
that's crazy did not feel needed feel
heartbreak there's so much I wanted
power to what people would need me
whether I yeah they love me or not
that's right and that's a that's a big
Epiphany feeling that for Mankind
through because all my trips all the way
back to the beginning so feeling that
all the his the history of that so big
throughout Mankind's existence
for seven hours
to where I ended up in the tub in the
fetal position because I wanted my be in
my mother's womb yeah
I've done that in a hot tub
and I was like
it was really weird it was cool though
so my girl came in and hugged me like
and I remember looking at her not what
broke that was me looking at her eyes
and seeing nature in the pasture and I
was like this is what love is and it's
such a peaceful thing and I'll never
forget that because
that's what calms me down sometimes when
I'm angry and it's beautiful
you got a lot of wisdom man I love this
I'm loving this chat I wish we weren't a
little short on time I'm going to ask
you the last question I feel like I
could talk to you for another two hours
that's that's just to compliment you
um can you tell me just because we've
gone to everyone meaning and all that
here's a light question can you tell me
a time in your life you laugh so hard
you cried something stupid happened
someone fell down maybe someone farted
it's still dark it hit me I was hustling
even if I was 18 I stopped hustling you
were dealing drugs yeah and uh I was at
a low I wanted to kill myself and I was
going through all the ways I wanted to
kill myself but I couldn't afford some
of the ways to kill myself which made me
even more sad
[Music]
yes
I found my sense of humor wow to me God
me and God was talking to God I was like
do it jump out the window that's free
but he was like oh you're on the first
floor so you ain't gonna die you're
gonna be in a wheelchair at the club
[__] up explaining to people why you
jumped out of the window oh my God so
God roasted you yeah we was we just you
know so this is how this is our
this is me and gods
not only communication but our
relationship
um you know so it was fun laughing you
know come out the window yeah yeah do it
oh sorry you're not in the penthouse
building that's not gonna do anything
yeah you're gonna be at the club in the
wheelchair telling people drinking
somebody got to put a straw with the
coolest light with a straw you know uh
so I mean it was just so funny and I
couldn't hang myself you can't hang
yourself because you're black
that's a no that's a no automatically oh
my God is that a thing I'm not trying to
be I don't know what he's adults I don't
know there's a thing or not but you
definitely it's just not yes I mean I
immediately understood yeah yeah yeah so
uh he's like you already cut yourself
use the butter knife but that so uh you
can't afford a nice knife yeah yeah this
is a dark bed but it's not it's it's
just where I found everything I think
that's why my conversation my jokes
always go to these real yeah weird Dark
Places or why I do dramas versus I don't
do comedies as much yeah you know
because it's like I could I could find
funny in this yeah thing yeah
um
so that's really interesting well I want
you to keep doing it because it's really
working and I haven't seen a special
that is like yours you know what I mean
there's like
it shouldn't have been a special it
should have been like a short film or
something because it's oh interesting
yeah but you know because I had to
promote it that way they they was like
uh at first like you should go do a sit
on Colbert I'm like you can't do this
upset about this and talk about it in a
way like how we having conversations and
patterns and stuff like that so I'm
realizing like yeah it could have been
this a film like a sword Indie but maybe
next time because you got a lot left I
love it it's really interesting thank
you man sorry to wrap up but incredible
I'm glad you we we're trying for years
yeah make this happen well this is just
time now yeah we're we're
at a time in our lives when we had this
conversation we wouldn't have been this
that's right that's true and you did my
first hey he did my first my first TV
appearance show that's right and I Crush
it's probably my best TV performance
yeah look that up too the Pete home show
yeah my best performance no that's real
I remember JP Buckman shout out to JP
Buck JP Buck
um well and obviously I was like
absolutely but JP deserves the credit
for that yeah I was happy to have you
and he gave me that break too JP got me
that shout out shout out to JP JP uh all
right man thank you so much this was
awesome people are gonna love it check
out the special I can't say the title
you say it spiritual [__] you would say
spiritual n-word spiritual n-word Daniel
Van Kirk was like in work think of
inward
spiritual inward oh that seems like if
we were on drugs we would have thought
that was incredible that's incredible to
me wait
inward inward inward
so when I redo the truck I'm like I'm
definitely throwing that on there that's
great but nobody we'll know what it is
but nobody else does that's right and we
ended on the truck we began on the truck
this was its own sine wave this was a
pattern and that's how I should be
remember that would you say keep it
crispy it's how we close you say crispy
hey I don't care what you do out there
how you like it this is the most
important thing you could do in life
keep it crispy
[Music]